our camera has come to the YMCA located
on alala street at the center of Gaza
City these premises were entirely
destroyed by the Israeli occupation
forces then the Israeli soldiers on the
ground storm what was left of the
building many families had taken Refuge
inside the
premises and now standing in the middle
of the yard at the YMCA gazans have come
to bury their dead those who were killed
while taking shelter inside the premises
at the time of the Israeli occupation
forces
shelling the Israeli occupation forces
kept shelling and firing on us while we
were inside eight people were killed and
dozens injured all of us are civilians
unarmed innocent
civilians this is a mass grave where the
victims who died inside the YMCA are
buried what was left of the premises
after the Israeli occupation forces
destroyed it was eaten by the Flames
nothing was
spared make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer